part of the idea of believing that what
happens to other black people
affects you and recognizing that you're
not just an individual but that
politically because of the social marker
of race
and the social stigma of race that your
identity is salient
and that it makes sense for people to
join together to try to collectively
improve their community and their group
status within the community
that also creates opportunities for
healing because you don't have to suffer
this alone
other people saw the exact same thing
that you do that you did
and if you talk about it right there
that's a way to help work through
some of that trauma together
welcome to the first episode of the adi
hour i'm really excited to get this
program off the ground
and really thrilled to introduce you to
some great guests as we talk through
some really important
and some really deep content at times so
just before we jump into this first
episode i do want to set the stage just
a little bit and to say that one of the
things
i'm really trying to do on this podcast
is to pair
unique individuals from really different
walks of life who can come and share
on the same topic and share from their
unique perspectives
from their professional expertise and
from their lived experience
so i think there's going to be a lot of
great content that we're going to be
able to talk through together and i'm
happy to be able to bring that to you
through this series um and with that i'm
really excited to welcome the first two
guests on the program
dr jeff gardeer and dr andre gillespie
so welcome to both of you
thank you thank you and these are names
that you definitely should know if you
don't you'll definitely know them well
after our conversation today
but by way of brief introduction did
want to introduce both of them to you
before we jump into the conversation
um so we'll start with dr jeff gardier
he's also known as america's
psychologist
he's a clinical psychologist who has a
private practice in manhattan
and he's also an associate professor at
the toro college of osteopathic medicine
in new york city
um dr jeff has a very impressive
background he's a very prolific author
he's also contributed to documentaries
as a producer as well
um he's also been a and appeared on
multiple national
uh news outlets he's been on the fox
network on today's show
also on msnbc and on cnn and in his own
words he has appeared on rapid tv
on occasion as well so i did want to
mention that um but he's also a really
devoted family man he's a father of six
he has lots of great hobbies he really
enjoys volunteering enjoys giving back
to the community he also enjoys daily
exercise and is very disciplined about
that
and enjoys attending religious services
so we're honored to have dr
jeff on the program i should also
mention he's a interfaith ordained
minister so several different aspects
that definitely tie into what we want to
bring out today
so thanks for being here dr jeff it's a
pleasure wow what an introduction i
didn't even know half those things about
myself
thank you it's good to be your mind it's
good to be reminded
um also a pleasure to welcome dr andre
gillespie to the program
andre's an associate professor of
political science at emory university
and also the director of the james
weldon johnston institute for the study
of race and difference and i definitely
had to read that because i don't think i
would have remembered all those words
it's a very impressive um position that
she has there
uh she did her phd training at yale
university so there is a little bit of
an overlap there we did overlap with eo
in our grand training
and it's great to be able to reconnect
with her in this way
um embry she teaches a host of different
classes on american politics
race and politics and also on aspects of
qualitative methodology
in terms of her research she focuses on
political leadership
of the post-civil rights generation and
she also does work looking specifically
at african-american politicians and
political leadership
that transcends race and how black
voters respond to those individuals
so a lot of the topics that she
emphasizes and studies on are really
relevant to the topics we'll be
discussing today
she's also an accomplished author with
numerous books um she's an active public
scholar
also has written op-eds and done
interviews on numerous local
and national and international media
outlets
so great very grateful to have dr andre
gillespie on the program today as well
thank you so with that before we get
into some of the the nitty-gritty i just
want to ask at the very baseline how
both of you all are doing in the midst
of everything that's happening in our
world today everything that's happening
in your personal lives
so andre why don't we start with you how
are you how are you managing these days
with everything
um i think i'm struggling and managing
the same way that everybody else is um
my quarantine experience um in part
because
of the racial tension and because i
study campaigns on elections
means that uh my work increased uh you
know over the last year and so that's
certainly a
challenge to try to balance it out um
staying at home sometimes makes it a
little bit easier to take on all of
those responsibilities but it's
certainly given me a lot
of food for thought in terms of what my
post covet life looks like and what
balance actually looks like both during
quarantine and after quarantine
and so i can't say that i've perfected
it at all um but you know i've certainly
learned a lot about myself and learned a
lot about what my limits are
and envisioning what my post covet
limits and balance
is going to look like as i still work to
try to make sure that i'm doing this
right and making sure that i'm i'm being
a balanced person i can't always say
that i'm
always the most balanced in terms of my
work
yeah well definitely appreciate that
honesty and i mean i agree with you in a
lot of ways it really is
something that we're all learning over
time and so i appreciate the way that
you
mentioned that and also it seems that
you're also giving yourself grace to
know that it's not going to be perfected
and there's things that you're learning
as you go and things that you'll have to
learn on the other side as well and i
think that's really healthy
for all of us to remember what about you
jeff how are you how are you
managing and handling things in this
moment
well it's uh certainly um i can cry
salty tears as to what has happened
politically and i know you'll be getting
into that
um to america and certainly how
uh the virus has been mismanaged in um
the past year or so
uh seems like it's been forever
certainly and we have a lot of high
hopes with the biden
administration to fix that and it looks
like it is moving forward on the right
track
uh but uh along with that and and
mourning the people who have died and
gotten sick and uh certainly opened our
eyes to all of the uh
political changes financial changes
um sociological changes um uh
in the world uh including the global
warming and so on
uh and and just really watching that
in a way where i go to bed
every night with my mouth open i wake up
every morning with my mouth open i
cannot believe
what has happened to our world at the
same time
it's also been a very strange and
beautiful existence
um being in the house every single day
i'm virtually in exile and i've chosen
that particular life i've taken
joy and pleasure in it uh seeing my
family every day seeing my children
every day
as a matter of fact i saw the kids a
couple of weeks ago in the kitchen
and i had to ask my wife uh who are
those kids she was like those are your
kids
i was like wow finally i get to
recognize and spend time with them and i
know dr gillespie perhaps goes through
that too
uh but it certainly was um
[Music]
being home every day has given me the
time to pause and think
about what life is about uh and what it
is that i need to do once we go back
out into the world uh but i i have to
say this and and
i'll keep quiet uh after this um
if i never had to leave this house or
this property that i'm in and you could
see a little bit of it
you know from my window if i never had
to leave again
i think i would just stay here and work
for the rest of my life
and i'm a guy who's a manhattanite and
all of that
but it certainly has changed things for
me
uh in a very dramatic way as it has for
everyone else
yeah yeah i think that's very well said
i mean so many important components that
you're bringing out as well
i mean all the changes that are are
associated with everything that we're
going through
both the ones that are not good and the
ones that they're
where there is some silver lining
there's some things that we're trying to
to grow in in the meantime too
so definitely appreciate you are you
bringing those to light and yes there's
definitely aspects of that we'll be
looking back into
as we as we move forward in this
conversation um so both of you have
hinted at this already in terms of some
of these really important topics but i'm
also curious you know what attracted you
to this podcast in particular i mean
obviously there's numerous podcasts out
there you're both very prolific you're
both in the media space there's lots of
ways you could be spending your time
why take the time to to jump on here and
to jump into the conversation in this
space in particular
uh jeff if you want to jump in that
would be great
well i certainly knowing the work that
you've done
uh nia's for me it's been just like
absolutely amazing that you bring a real
clarity
uh into the things that we do and why we
do them
and certainly i couldn't think of a
better podcast to be on
and i get a lot of offers like dr
gillespie you know to do these media
hits and to do
you know these podcasts but i knew this
is a place where we can have uh not just
an
intellectual but an emotional a
discussion to try to figure out where we
are
in this very upside down world and how
we make it
right side up perhaps well said i
appreciate those kind words and getting
to right side up is definitely the goal
uh what about you andrew what pulled you
in
well i mean you asked so of course i was
going uh
to help you out um and to honor i could
have known you and your wife for almost
20 years
at this point um you know i have to
admit when i first heard
you know what the topic was my first
reaction was i'm qualified to talk about
that because my research isn't about
mental health
uh but then you know through some
additional conversation
i you know realized that what you wanted
me to talk about was to talk about
the context um and so i can provide
kind of the political context and then i
can talk about mental health from a
personal standpoint so i will say that
kind of you know just as a preface
you know i'm not a mental health
professional um in the same way that dr
jeff is
so uh you know you go to him for it like
your specific clinical advice
um and i i would be there to affirm that
the things that
you're seeing may or may not be the way
that they are so
yeah yeah very well said we definitely
appreciate you know your willingness to
jump in that way and i think that's part
of the the beauty of it too
because as you hint to that we don't
always have these types of intersecting
conversations
even though they definitely influence
one another so i'm hoping that's
something we can really unpack
in a conversation today and in this
series in general as we do that with
some of the other topics as well
um but just to follow up on that andre
if you could just give us a little bit
of a taste for
from your lens of what you see as our in
a way our current
political health as a society what what
does that look like at the moment where
are we sitting
you know i wish i could be optimistic
and i am optimistic
because i do think that there is uh the
potential for reform and the potential
for reconciliation in the offing
but if i had to look at the current
state of america i have to acknowledge
there are problems and there are serious
problems
they didn't change uh before after
january 6th
they didn't change before or after
january 20th
and i think it's important for us to
realize that america is just as sick and
just as divided
uh now with the new administration as it
was previously
um and it's going to be really important
for us to spend the time i know people
want to move past things
sometimes they want to do that for
political reasons but it's important for
us to diagnose and address
the problems that brought us to january
6
that brought us to the last four years
because i think that that's more of a
symptom
than a cause of anything in order to
address those issues and move forward so
all of the problems in terms of partisan
polarization all the problems in terms
of racial division
all of the problems in terms of people
jockeying for position and putting power
and sometimes party ahead of what's good
for the country
all of the structural problems that were
made they never laid bare by what we've
seen happen
in um the last few years are still there
um and we could ignore it and then kick
the can down the road and have
another eruption in a few years or we
could try to address these problems once
and for
all um and put us in a better position
so that we're more democratic so that
we're more just
um and what i see right now is the
tension between people who i think
have the will and the willingness to you
know have those hard conversations
um and people who don't want to have
those hard conversations and i think
we need to recognize is that those
groups are actually more evenly matched
numerically um then some of us perhaps
would want them to be and so we're gonna
have to figure out a way to bring people
along
to have that you know to have that
moment where they're actually willing to
say that and so
you know i wish we could say that we hit
rock bottom on january 6th
i'm not sure that that is in fact the
case wow
wow there's a lot there and i appreciate
you just really digging in and point out
you know the reality of
of these things i mean these are more
symptoms than than the core issue and
the importance for us to really be able
to dig in and address those and we're
definitely going to come back to talk
about some of the things that we need to
do
to be able to effectively work through
it and then move forward and not just
move on
but why you've brought up some of those
points i wanted to pivot to jeff and
just
ask you you know in the midst of
everything that andre just brought up
how does that
impact us as a society when we're
thinking about our emotional wellness
and our mental health
like what's the what's the relationship
between those
well i i think um uh certainly with uh
what andres uh pointed out the uh
political instability uh the contagion
didn't use these words but
uh the continued racism and white
supremacy and how
it has been divisive for our nation uh
from the very beginning right up until
now
i think more than anything else this has
been an affirmation for us
that we as black and brown people and
those of us who are
uh uh diverse liberal uh whites and so
on
that um we're not crazy we weren't
making this up
we weren't uh acting as victims this is
something
that is structural and has been built
into the foundation
of the united states and you know many
parts of the world and so that
affirmation and i think
for me uh as a black person has uh
lent me a little bit more sanity because
it is
the truth we are seeing what what is
part
of uh what is going on part of the
process here
and what it is that we need to continue
uh to address uh
and to try to fix um but that being said
i've never seen so much uh
traumatization and re-traumatization
of black and brown people by watching
the images on
um on television and other media sources
uh with the capital insurrection the way
the individuals
were very uh narcissistic uh acted out
in uh
very unstable ways or very determined um
in the way that they were attacked uh
now that we're finding out of course
uh that there may have been some
coordination with you know
others uh within certain places
i think all of those things not only
remind
us and are an affirmation which in some
ways as i said is healthy
that now we know what we're seeing is
real
um but it also is a
constant trauma that was seeing the way
that people
act out the way they're trying to um
uh stop us from voting uh the continued
oppression
all of those things uh i think really
contribute to our post-traumatic stress
disorder
continue uh to contribute to our
post-traumatic slavery disorder
but continue to keep us emotionally
unstable and why
now we as mental health professionals
have to address these issues in therapy
and really look at positive mental
attitude spirituality
empowerment strategies um strategies
working within the political system
uh and every other system to address
these issues
yeah so important so important on so
many fronts and you both brought out so
many important topics as well i mean
i think one thing that runs through both
of your comments and something that a
lot of us talk about is that these
things aren't new
so in some ways sometimes it feels to
sound like it's a new conversation
but it really isn't i mean these things
have been embedded and ongoing and in a
sense
i do see some ways that the people are
listening with more of an ear for
empathy than they have in the past
um at times where people might have
brushed it off or just assumed that
those were things that were happening
out there that weren't really happening
right here where they were
or didn't realize that these were things
that were happening to people they knew
so even for me as i've shared my story
that it's people feel shocked that
someone that they work with interact
with is having these same experiences in
their mind somehow they just put that
out there as other
so i think there is a better
understanding i mean there's still a lot
and a long way to go in terms of that
but really reconciling the fact that
these aren't
fringe episodes or fringe things are
happening this is baked and it's
happening across the board in so many
different ways
um and then jeffy talked about just all
the ramifications of that as well
um and so you know as a mental health
professional
and you start to talk about this a
little bit in some in terms of some of
the practices but how do we
deal with the state that we're at in
really terms in terms of trying to
really address it and this ties into
what andrew was talking about in terms
of the political piece as well these
aren't things that we can ignore but we
really have to dig in and say
we do need to address it so where do we
start
well let me say this to your prior point
what a difference
a pandemic makes right because it is the
pandemic
and everything that came along with it
of course
uh first we didn't understand but now
you can connect the dots we've never
been through a pandemic
in our particular uh you know since the
last hundred years so
now we're seeing how everything connects
but it is the pandemic itself
that really opened up the eyes and the
hearts of
many uh provided them the empathy to
understand
what social injustice uh looks like and
what it feels like and what people have
been going through
forever because they were feeling the
pain too this was a universal pain
that actually changed the trajectory of
the world absolutely extraordinary
um and so what we need to do uh i
believe and
and i'm sure many people uh agree is
addressing the mental health tsunami
that came after as part of this coven 19
uh pandemic
that we are going through can continue
to go through
and so that means now um more than
ever uh not only addressing mental
illness
but the importance of mental health as
being
part of our everyday lives it's not just
about
you know you as you know i love to
exercise
uh every day but we also now have to
exercise
our minds we have to exercise our
spirituality
we have to be able to connect with other
people and talk about the pain
our informal support groups our formal
support groups
our therapy we're seeing more people uh
including people of color coming into
therapy
than ever before as a matter of fact
when we look at the general population
uh a poll showed that one in six
americans in 2020 actually
accessed mental uh health treatment and
that is
incredible in some ways it's very sad
that it had to happen that way
in some ways it's very encouraging and
that finally we're addressing
the importance of being strong
emotionally so those are the things we
have to keep
pushing forward and smashing that stigma
of talking about mental illness in the
black and brown and
other communities and continuing to
address that every day
actively so well said and on so many
levels
yeah i mean as you mentioned that it's
encouraging disappointing and
encouraging at the same time but i think
there's a lot that we can take from that
to say okay well look we are starting to
address it and we're not just moving on
and yes we have made progress in terms
of decreasing stigma but you're right we
still have to really smash that
that ethos and get past that to really
get to a place where we can have healing
um and in the same token andre i was
just curious to hear your thoughts
because you've talked about this um you
hinted at this already and talked about
elsewhere like what do we need to do
to move forward in terms of also equally
importantly addressing
some of these political tensions that
are sitting and that we've seen we've
already seen when we ignore them they
just bubble up
and more than bubble up they explode so
what do we do to
i almost want to say prevent that from
continuing to happen as a cycle
well that's very complicated um and
complex
um because in the political arena people
have to
contend with the fact that uh some
people who actually have helped to
helmet the division
are in power and are likely to stay in
power structurally
because they're coming from districts or
they're coming from states
where people have a diametrically
opposed view
to the situation where you have people
who
perhaps you know believe that donald
trump really had the election stolen
from him
um or people uh who uh actually see
themselves pitted
against uh folks of the opposing
political party
um and something that to them would be
existential and equivalent
to like a partisan death match and so uh
we have to figure out as individuals and
then we have to actually have to hold
our leaders accountable
for figuring out ways to lower the
temperature
and that's really difficult in this
moment when not everybody is actually
willing to work together
um so i actually was just teaching this
in my class
we've seen increasing evidence of what
we call negative partisanship
um so it's a concept that was coined by
one of my colleagues and his graduate
students at emory
um and the idea of negative partisanship
is not that i choose my political party
per se because of what i believe in but
because i framed it in a way that says
well i know i don't believe what those
other folks are thinking um
and so while that can be clarifying it
also has the potential to other
people and that has serious consequences
when we see people being other
like you know taken to sort of you know
its end right that's when genocide
happens right because i mean if you
think about historically
the ways that things have happened like
that's justified people feeling that
it's okay to inflict violence against
people
um and to try to eliminate people and
we've seen that in our rhetoric where
you've seen social media posts
where people think it's perfectly okay
to talk about executing their political
opponents
i'm like we shouldn't be talking about
that in the united states that runs
counter to our ideals
though we need to acknowledge
historically um how people have been
completely unabashed using violence when
it was convenient for their ends
um and whether that is sort of you know
absolutely holding you know people
up um you know um whether that's
enslavement whether that is denying
people their rights like there's just a
lot of violence in american history that
goes unacknowledged
um that that you know we have to say no
stop that's unacceptable
and i think we even have to say that
this is unacceptable
we rebuke and sometimes we've removed
people from office even when
we agree with them even when politically
it's advantageous
to keep these folks in office because
they're going to vote the way that you
want
on certain types of issues and that
because of negative partisanship because
of polarization is the unwillingness
that i've seen people do
right i mean it's how you can have
somebody say
you know what i think donald trump
caused a riot
um but i'm not going to vote to
like victim in an impeachment trial and
if he runs for president again you know
what i'm going to support him right
because we got the same letter behind
our name
and i think people who are democrats
also need to acknowledge
that there are people who would use the
same twisted logic
for a member of their own party if it
met their end
now right now i'm not trying to create a
false equivalency right because we saw a
lot of that in the last couple of weeks
and i haven't seen democrats actually
like you know trying to start a riot
recently right now but in theory there
could be some crazy person who decides
that that is the way to go
and democrats would then be on the hot
seat and have the responsibility to
stand up against that
um i think that we just need some
courageous people more of them
who are actually willing to stand up and
speak truth to power wherever it
is and actually be willing to take the
risk the short-term political loss
of their careers i haven't seen that
happen
and so as voters and we need to take
that voting responsibility seriously
and not just turn out in record-breaking
numbers because the country caught on
fire
um in some cases almost literally when
we think about sort of you know
the environmental disasters that have
happened in the west but that you know
look different on the east coast where
you know when we see flooding um
but like the country was literally on
fire because of covet or because of
wildfires or because
of uh demands for racial justice and all
of a sudden everybody realized what the
stakes are
yeah no those stakes are important when
you're voting for dog catcher when
you're voting for city council
when you're voting for your state
legislative state legislatures
and sometimes some of these people
come into sort of like their public
service careers
via some of these other routes and if
you want to stop that and say that we
don't stand for that type of uncivil
behavior
uh we don't stand for people who want to
be revisionist in their history and deny
racism and deny marginalization
right you got to stop them wherever you
know whatever level they're running for
office even if they held office for a
long period of time
and maybe if they've been in the past
they've done nice things for you
wow there's a lot there so many things
we could we could respond to i mean
i think you've pulled out again so many
important concepts and i think this
piece about
whether it's reactionary versus whether
we're in this for the long haul and
really having some proactive measures
um but i'm also curious because you've
painted a picture in terms of what needs
to happen
at a leadership level i'm curious what
you what do you feel like is a
responsibility and you mentioned this as
well but
on the individual level versus the
large-scale leadership political level
and if there's any intersection between
those two
i think that there's a lot of
intersection i think a lot of people
think that polarization is this thing
that people in washington dc do um or
that people may be doing in their
respective state capitals
no i mean those leaders come from the
masses
um and those leaders are getting their
cues from the masses
and one of the things that's actually
been really interesting is that you know
we always talk about and and perhaps
in your high school studies class you
heard about the difference between
trustee and delegate representation when
we elect people
um you know are they there to just kind
of put their finger up in the wind and
then just vote the way that they think
the people in their constituency want
them to vote
are they there to be able to make tough
decisions maybe technical decisions that
are based on expertise and learning
and and a lot of politicians kind of use
some combination of both kind of
depending on which issue was at hand
um in the last month it's been funny to
see uh people go up to their leaders and
hold them accountable if you will
because they were like we didn't send
you there to think we
sent you there to do our bidding and it
was like yeah well sometimes true
leadership means
uh that you stand up and say you know
what your per
your your preference your personal
opinion is based in
in a lie so i so it's my responsibility
to show you that that's a lie and then
help bring you to
a different place but that also suggests
that there
are people who can be easily led into a
type of mob
mentality where they're not thinking um
and so we have to
guard ourselves against sort of becoming
part of the mob
so part of that is making sure that in
terms of your own media consumption
that you are guarding your heart so it's
really nice to go into your echo chamber
whatever echo chamber that is
um and only read and consume the stuff
that already confirms what you think
right sometimes that stuff isn't true um
and there are some ways that you can
think about it so the tools that i give
to
you know my students are you know if
you're watching cable news you know
prime time gets really opinionated
certain time time of day like you know
eight to eleven 9 to 11 in particular
right those folks may be journalists
they may not be journalists so you
should know the background of your tv
posts
and know sort of like when they're
actually like spouting off of their
opinion
versus when they're delivering hard news
uh you should know when they have round
tables kind of like you know who are the
journalists
who are the political hacks who are
there who's there to be objective
uh to provide outside information also
you should vet
sources so if one news outlet is
reporting something
and other credible establishment news
outlets are not reporting it
you might be suspect they could be on
the vanguard and other folks could catch
up eventually
but that is a clue that if one news
source is picking it up and other people
aren't that
they're this may not be true so i would
uh you know not necessarily forward that
on facebook uh
if you can't verify the source of what's
going on
and then you know there are other places
that are trusted where these people have
no idea what they're doing
um these people don't have any training
they don't have accountability
they don't have any editors you
shouldn't be listening to that as well
and i wouldn't trust any news source
that doesn't have an ombudsperson
and that doesn't have a history of
retractions right because all
journalists make mistakes
and the difference between journalism
and propaganda is that journalists will
correct mistakes
propagandas don't and so you have to
understand what it is that you're that
you're listening to
and it's okay sometimes to cut it off
like so you don't need the
even though news is on 24 hours a day
you don't have to watch it 24 hours a
day you should probably go sleep some
spend time with your family and the real
news will still be there when you get
that
yeah that's really that's really good
you're you're touching on some of the
mental health too you're already putting
in some of those practices you made your
disclaimer about not being a mental
health expert guys things you got some
good tools uh
that you're sharing with our listeners
already but i think yeah everything you
mentioned is is so spot on
jeff i was curious with everything that
andreas mentioned how you advise people
as she's been talking about in their
media consumption both in terms of how
much to take
in but then also in terms of what she's
talking about about discernment
and how how do we react to some of those
things because some of the things that
are happening are real and we've touched
on that that affects people but how do
you guide people in terms of those
those responses to everything that's
happening in politics and in the media
well andre was spied on with her advice
uh
and one of the things that we say is
mental health experts is
um know when you've reached your
saturation level
uh when it comes to consuming the news
be able to get what it is that you want
because breaking news
is the same news that's being played
over and over and over and over
again and so breaking news ain't what it
used to be
so you can get that information quickly
and then once you get it
then go on to something else that
relaxes you
as you are absolutely processing that
information
um and as well as she has said
again the importance of getting it from
different news sources
uh because uh certainly you don't want
your information to be
homogeneous because then you're not
getting different
opinions it's not allowing you to think
it's not allowing you to process
it uh by hearing the different voices
and giving you
much more information but one of the
most important things that i think that
um you should really consider is that
we've lost
many friendships we've lost many family
connections
because of the partisan politics what it
is that we're hearing in the news what
it is
you know that we have come to believe
and so it's important
that you stay connected to your friends
to your family
to people that you may work with who not
only have the same
opinions but especially who have
differing opinions
because there you find common ground you
try to find common ground
you learn something new uh it's not only
the
intellectual um processes
that increase but also your social iq
uh but more than anything else you want
to maintain those connections with other
people
because it goes beyond the news it goes
to your
humanity and learning how to live
in a world how to live in a country
where people have differing
opinions but you can respect their
opinions
especially if they're not based on hate
and racism
and prejudice but are based more than
anything
on having different perceptions that's
what's always made
america when it has been great great but
that's what
makes us as human beings um
the social uh kinds of people
uh that we are it's important to
maintain those connections
especially in times like these yeah i
think that's so important
and you've both made so many great
points i mean i think there's so much
rich content that people can really
dig into here and really think about
aspects where
you know we've all fallen short i mean
we're human especially in this time with
covert i think one of the
main things that we've had to we
emphasize for ourselves i know i've had
to re-emphasize for my students as well
is
to give ourselves at times know that
things are more difficult than they
usually are
and they're going to be a lot more
missteps than we used than we were
typically
accustomed to taking in the first place
but to again have that willingness to be
able to forgive ourselves and forgive
those around us and i guess i mean i
guess
i think that gets to your point jeff as
well and to andre's point about really
being able to get and have community
beyond the differences
andre i think you hit that point very
early on as you were talking about just
how the differences are so deep seated
and you've talked about some of the the
frameworks from how people are
focusing on the uttering more and more
than they have in the past not that it
wasn't there in the past in other ways
but how dangerous
that can be in a lot of ways so
definitely appreciate both the points
that you are are pulling out in this
conversation
um as we wrap up i did want to just talk
briefly about
some of the additional steps that we
think about in communities of color
as well and how we move on so or how we
try to move on
after having moved through so there was
an article in the new york times a
couple weeks ago specifically from black
staffers who were
at the capitol working on january 6 and
they talked a lot about
their specific traumatization that
happened in that moment i mean they
assumed that of all places
as black individuals in this country
that they would be safe in that
environment
and all the fears that they had fear for
losing their lives in that situation
and then all the stress that they've no
they've felt after the fact and even
just saying okay
you know sometimes um if we haven't gone
through it the post-traumatic stress can
feel like it's an intellectual
thing that we're talking about once you
go through a situation like that then
you realize okay this is real
um and so i'm curious from both of you
how as as
for black individuals all the
ramifications of that moment
and how we process that moving forward
both from a political
framework and also from our mental
health framework
so this might sound a little weird
but in some ways i think
that there were affirming moments in
this as as
tragic as this was i think it is
important to acknowledge
uh that for many folks this wasn't a
surprise
like we knew that white supremacy
has sort of you know um violent goals
and that they could manifest
themselves and i don't think anybody
woke up per se on january 6
other than the people who were planning
um that riot and expected that to happen
but on the other hand uh people who are
armed with the knowledge that white
supremacy is violent
um weren't shocked by what they saw even
though as citizens
in the moment you can be shocked and
horrified by what it is that you're
seeing
and so i use the term affirming to say
that it affirms
what people knew deep down in their
core about racism right so that you're
not
shocked or surprised by what you saw
and it also counters those who wanted to
say that america isn't racist
or that america was passed race but we
took care of all that in the 1960s
surely after barack obama there is no
such thing as racism
um in america anymore um all
donald trump was doing mouthing off
right like yeah no
we knew that that was made fair
um and there's a strange comfort in
knowing that you aren't crazy
that your experience uh is real and that
it is
tied to the experience of other people
and the other thing that i think is
really interesting is sort of this idea
of community
and i think that there are mental health
applications for this in political
science we
always talk about group consciousness
within
the african-american community we talk
about a political psychological concept
called linked fate
which makes it highly predictive of
african-american political behavior
in terms of policy preferences in terms
of voting behavior and other kinds of
things
it's that thing that makes black people
look alike even though there's a lot of
heterogeneity in black
communities right but part of the idea
of believing that what happens to other
black people affects you
and recognizing that you're not just an
individual but that politically because
of the social marker of race
and the social stigma of race that your
identity is salient
um and that it makes sense for people to
join together to try to collectively
improve their community and their group
status within the community
that also creates opportunities for
healing because you don't have to suffer
this alone
other people saw the exact same thing
that you do that you did
and if you talk about it right that
there that's a way to help work through
some of that trauma together because you
know part of the trauma is isolation
is feeling that you're the only one and
uh you weren't there were lots of people
who saw that
and they weren't always all black um you
know who saw that but in particular with
respect to the african-american
community
yeah i would say probably the vast
majority of the 44 million
of us in the united states kind of saw
that and understood
what was going on and there's a way for
us to be able to work together
um and and combat that and i think you
know there's some lessons like
uh you know you know post-traumatic
trauma and stress have been around
it may not have been named as such in
previous generations but we have a name
for it now
and we can talk through it um and
sometimes i think that there are
important lessons here
for how we talk about bad things um you
know and i
you know and i will leave it to jeff to
talk about when it's appropriate to
bring this up with children but i think
perhaps some of the shock
particularly for people who were younger
is is that they thought america was past
all this
in the last six years seven to eight
years have shown us
that um yeah we're really not past all
of this
but i actually you know as as troubling
and as dissatisfied and as frustrated as
i can be
that i can look back at what happened in
the 50s and what was happening in the 19
teens and 20s and what was happening in
the 1880s and 1890s sort of shows this
common thread
right right there's the frustration of
why are we still kind of treading the
same ground that we had before
but there's also a comfort in knowing
other people
saw this name this tried to combat it
and that we have an opportunity to kind
of push the ball forward
farther than they were able to because
of the tools and the freedoms that we
have at
our disposal and i think you know it's
better to have
intergenerational discussions about this
so that people don't understand that ooh
this is the first time we're
experiencing this and sometimes
our elders have tools that they haven't
always imparted to us
because they were trying not to
traumatize us and that wasn't a healthy
way for them to deal with their trauma
and it's not a healthy way to help us
deal with our trauma today so
i see opportunities and so that's why
i'm calling it affirming not that i
think that what happened on january 6th
is a good thing because of course that
was horrible
wow that's so good great i agree and and
uh you know specifically going to this
question about black journalists and
what they've uh
been through uh we know that they've
been traumatized and re-traumatized
um they are having some real issues
um dealing with the dichotomy
of reporting the news uh and telling the
truth
but telling it in a way that doesn't get
them
in trouble with the parent organization
where there may be people who are
extremely conservative
who may own those news outlets or are
getting people really
angry um the general public their
readers the people who watch them
by talking about what's really in their
hearts so they have to keep it
uh extremely professional and just
report it in a way
that uh reporting is usually done
not putting your emotions in it um
especially if you're just giving
straight news so they're facing the
wrath of some people
in that way who are saying we don't want
to know about your black
experience they're facing the wrath of
people who are saying
why aren't you telling us more about
your black
experience um and then we know that
traditionally
uh that um uh black journalists
um black broadcasters and so on uh
there's been systematic
institutional uh sorts of um
racism uh prejudice in the places that
they work
where they have been treated
traditionally as second and third class
citizens
not being given their due um feeling
like they are an outside group i know
this because i've done a lot of the work
uh with these journalists and so uh
traditionally there's been a ptsd as
andra
uh has talked about they've experienced
it
in all of these avenues but especially
with what's going
on in the world right now around covid
and around uh you know political
oppression
and uh you know and and uh social
injustice
but at the same time we also know and
this
is life in covid world right uh we also
know
uh that it's important for them to um be
able to hook up with
affinity groups uh so that they can talk
about some of their issues
uh and as well be able to connect with
one another
uh with regard to um informal support
groups
within their networks and also getting
that therapy
too yeah so well said by both of you and
yes that's definitely coveted life as
you've demonstrated for us very well
did you see the mom at the uh on the
floor saying
come back in my mind i envisioned that
so many so many important points i mean
i think you both just
the the affirmation and the tension
that's there and jeff as you even
mentioned with the journalist and i
think for
all of us in a lot of different ways and
i think that's that's part of the
challenge for us
really moving forward is to be able to
to lean into that
to both of those aspects and not ignore
either one of those andre i love the
point that you you
mentioned about the elders bringing in
aspects that they can help us with
through as well
whereas some of those things might not
have been spoken about before for
fear of re-traumatization but as we're
all going through it already
i mean the time is is definitely
appropriate um there's so much more that
we could have jumped into i definitely
appreciate both of you
uh being here and for the listeners this
is obviously an ongoing conversation
we'll be having from different angles
on the addie hour moving forward um but
i'm deeply appreciative to both dr jeff
gardeire and dr andre gillespie for
joining on this first episode for really
launching and giving us a lot to think
about
these are conversations that as you'll
see we'll have some takeaways but
there's things that we'll also be able
to continue to think about
throughout the week so again just deeply
appreciative to both of you for being
willing to jump in
on this first episode and for really
setting the tone for how things will go
moving forward
thank you thank you it was it was an
honor and a pleasure to be on the addie
hour
and to spend the time uh also with you
andra
uh you are spot on in everything you say
and i can listen to you
forever but oh i appreciate that
i appreciate that i've been watching
this for years so this has been fun
thank you but i'll be listening to you
on the addie hour
[Laughter]
thanks again to both of you and for our
listeners stay tuned for some great
episodes coming up
[Music]
you